SPEAKER: So please give a warm
welcome to educator and spoken
word artist, Joseph Green.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSEPH GREEN: There's a moment
when I walk onto a stage
or walk into a
classroom, whether it
be middle school, high
school, elementary, college,
walk into a boardroom of a
million member organization,
or merely walk into my
four-year-old son's room,
there's a moment where I
panic and I worry about
whether or not I'm going
to be able to create
the necessary connection with
the people in that space,
because if I can't then
why did I come here?
What was the reason for me
choosing to speak in this space
and be present in it?
So I'm having that
same moment right now.
And it's going to
motivate me, I believe,
to try my hardest
to reach everybody
who's listening in a particular
and unique way for them.
The power of story is best
shown through storytelling.
So I'm going to jump right
into the deep end here,
and I'm going to do a poem--
a spoken word poem--
to begin.
And up until three
days ago I was
going to do a completely
different poem to start,
but this has happened
again, and again, and again,
and it affects the young
people I work with.
It affects me as a black man.
It affects my son as
a person of color,
who will one day be 6' 7",
if the doctors are correct.
And so I felt like if I was
going to have an opportunity
to speak at Google, which
is a big deal to me,
if I was going to
have this opportunity
to try to encapsulate within
45 minutes my life work
and what that means
to me, I would
have to be true to
the voice inside,
and this is what the
voice inside has to say.
He's a nice guy.
This poem is
dedicated to my son,
to all those fighting
for black lives.
"Today I am doused in
guilt, and I don't know
what to do with these hands.
Facebook and Twitter
have informed me
that my friends have joined
together in digital solidarity
to fight for our
rights, or your memory,
so this never happens again.
Photos from the front
line of our most righteous
of selves, inspirational
memes, and hashtags.
I realize this has
happened before.
I wonder if I listen to the
recordings of your murder,
will I feel anything
different to me?
Your life and death is no
more than a Facebook update,
a trending topic on Twitter.
#Ihopesomebodyis
stillprayingforyourmother.
#insertyourchild'snamehere.
#allblackbodiesl
ookalikeuntilthey'remurdered.
I am overwhelmed by
the irrational rantings
of a society too busy
arguing about whether or not
black lives are important enough
to fight for, to actually fight
for black lives,
but as I stand here
ranting I realize it's
because I don't know
what to do with these hands that
must hold and protect my son.
They are not bulletproof.
They are made of the
same brown material
that I have seen
so many murdered.
But before I bow at the
altar of suburban flight,
I realize that somewhere
somebody is still
crying for you.
That somewhere a black
mother is gathering
all the suspicious
clothing her children own,
dressing the scarecrow
in the front yard
and burning our post-racial
society in effigy.
That somewhere a black female
is being followed in the Macy's
on suspicion of being black.
That somewhere hands
up, please don't shoot.
That somewhere why
did you shoot me?
You told me to get my ID.
That somewhere please
don't shoot, it's only a--
That somewhere I'm sorry my
music is too loud for you
to hear my humanity.
That somewhere, we
still can't breathe.
That somewhere they are toasting
the man who did this to you
and the clans are gathering.
Only this time they
won't be wearing hoods.
They'll be dressed in
suits, cloaked by law.
Charged with
progressing the doctrine
that if you do not look
like you belong here,
you can be murdered.
That if you look like you
belong here you can be murdered.
I will not always be
able to protect my son.
I pray that by then black
children and fear, black women
and violence, black queer
and assault, black trans
and endangered,
black male and thug,
black bodies and deceased
are no longer synonyms.
At night, when I take my
four-year-old son's clothes off
I say, "Hands up, Henry."
He thinks we are playing a game.
I pray that when his
time comes, he will
know what to do with his hands.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So what's the story
behind that poem?
I feel like I could have started
this presentation in many ways.
I could have said, Hi,
my name is Joseph Green.
And I could have added
to the resume of things
that I have accomplished, but
I feel like in our society
part of the problem is that
we start most conversations
as if what we do is who we are.
And as somebody who works with
young people on a regular basis
to create spaces where
they can share a story,
and believes that story is the
strongest fiber connecting us
as people, and nowadays the most
neglected fiber connecting us
is people, I thought it was
important to be vulnerable
first and say that I wrote that
poem out of the greatest fear
I've ever known.
I wrote that poem
because I was afraid
that if I didn't tell
my story, that I would
be complicit in my
son's death if something
were to ever happen to him.
And that means-- not that
everybody should find a stage
like this to speak--
but that everybody
has a story to share
and there are spaces where
it's appropriate to share.
This is what I do.
I have trained myself to be a
presenter of thoughts and ideas
and a facet of multiple, excuse
me, a multiplicity of spaces.
And sometimes I think when
I get into these spaces
and say, you should do
this, or like learning
how to share your story is
so important, that people
think I mean like this.
When I mainly mean
in conversation.
When I mainly mean over
Thanksgiving dinner.
When I mainly mean for
young people in spaces
where inappropriate
things are being
said, but they're
afraid to speak out
because of being ostracized.
When I grew up in
northern Virginia,
I grew up in a
primarily white space.
And what that creates is
an opportunity for you
to sympathize--
inappropriately-- on the behalf
of people who don't necessarily
need your sympathy or
deserve your sympathy, which
is to say that I went
around apologizing for all
of the white people
in my life because I
had good friends
which meant that,
oh, these people must have
within them the same thing
that my friends have,
even though there
were times when my friends
called me out of my name,
but they were my friends.
They were only
friends that I knew.
Even though my first
college girlfriend's family
suggested that they would
take her out of school
if she continued to date me.
Even though-- and I
kept making apologies
because I hadn't taken the
time to discover my story
as a black person in America.
And it's not the only
thing I identify.
As I say, I'm a male, I'm
a teacher, I'm an educator,
I'm a poet, but it's one of
the things that identifies me
before anything else does.
So obviously it's very important
in how I see and reflect myself
in society.
And so I originally wrote
that poem as a middle finger
to people who were
only using social media
to protest this issue.
And I wrote the poem
before my son was born.
So all of that stuff about my
son was added two years later.
I wrote the poem two weeks after
Trayvon Martin was murdered.
It was a challenge
from a friend of mine
who was tired of the type
of writing that I did,
which is basically family
relationships, and women,
and things of that sort,
things that I felt safe in,
because I had not taken the
time to examine what my role was
in America as a black man.
How dare I bring that up
as a topic in my writing,
in my poetry?
And so I wrote the poem.
I was lucky enough
to be on a team
from DC that represents DC
at the National Poetry Slam
that happens in a
different city every year.
It was actually in Oakland
the year that I went.
And I was challenged
by my teammates
to do something that I had been
challenging young people to do
for a decade at that point,
which was to strip away
your hate, and your
anger, and your fear,
and that which you use to
protect yourself from making
sincere connection
with the world,
and talk to me about the thing
that scares you the most.
Put that in this poem.
Put that in front of people
and see what type of reaction
you get.
That is the very essence
of what I do for a living.
Back in DC I started an
after-school creative writing
program, a nonprofit
called Poetry Now.
I ran it for five years and then
I was asked to work at a place
called Split This Rock, which
is poetry and social justice,
smushed into one.
They've been doing
it for 10 years.
They've had youth
programs for five.
I had programs at 14
schools in Virginia.
They had programs in
12 to 15 schools in DC.
We merged them
together and now my job
is director of youth
programs for Split This Rock.
And people ask me, do I think
poetry can save the world?
Because you speak of
it so passionately.
And I think about that poem
that I just did for you guys.
And I think about the--
at this point-- hundreds
of thousands of people
that I've performed it for.
And the work that it's gotten on
the internet and the response.
It was picked up by PBS.
It was put onto their website.
And the spaces where
I've gone, I've
done that poem in middle
schools in northern Virginia
where it's nothing but young
white people in the audience.
I've done that in
middle schools in DC
where there's nothing but young
black people in the audience.
And the conversations that
come from both of those spaces
would not have come if I had not
been willing to present myself
in that space, in that
way rather, in that space.
And so when we talk about how
do we get one another down
to have a conversation where
we're not screaming and yelling
facts and beliefs, I think
it starts with story.
And I've seen it happen
time and time again.
We sponsor an event
called the Hyperbole.
It's a clever name,
I came up with it.
Think about it.
[LAUGHTER]
You're not laughing, so I'm
assuming it didn't click it.
But that's OK,
it's all right, no.
Maybe it's just not funny.
Hyperbole is a play
off the word hyperbole.
We are the great-- there
you go, there you go.
All you googlers out there.
The idea is though,
we bring together
100 to 200 young
people into one space.
And these young people
have been working
on poems for about a year
in their individual clubs.
And they don't realize how
much they have in common
with one another.
And in DC--
I don't know what would be
comparable here-- but in DC
you have DC, Maryland,
and Virginia.
We call it the DMV.
Very different populations of
people in all three of those
places.
We purposely go out of
our way to bring people
from all of those
spaces together
to tell their story
to one another.
We do it through poetry.
Some people do it through song.
Some people do it
through painting.
through forensics,
which is speech and debate
and so on and so forth,
but we do we do
it through poetry.
And we find it to be
a very powerful tool.
And so they get together
and it's a competition.
It's also social
justice workshops.
It's also an open mic.
And it's also an
opportunity for one of them
to win a scholarship.
But above all of
that, it's one day
where they are asked to share
what's most important to them.
They're given space to do it.
It's at George Mason University.
So just imagine you're
a young man who's
never been off his
three blocks in DC
and you're transported in
the middle of George Mason
University.
And there are all
of these people
and they're all saying, oh
my, oh my god, your story.
It's amazing, it moves me.
And I can see now
for the first time
that beyond, behind
what is presented
to us on the news, what's
behind the fear that
drove our parents
to move out here
to the burbs in the first place,
behind the media, and movies,
and songs, and all of the
things that hit the mainstream,
you're just a dude.
And you like comic books.
And I like comic books.
Now, you live in a pretty
crappy neighborhood.
Why is it crappy?
Do I have anything
to do with that?
Does my privilege have anything
to do with creating that space?
?
Or can I use my privilege
to deconstruct that space?
Why are we so far apart
when geographically we
are so close together?
That's the power of
story to transform lives.
These young people
become doctors
and lawyers and activists.
I am not someone who is
a proponent of putting
more poets into the world.
I have enough
competition as it is.
And someone once said,
and I can't remember it,
but if you don't have
anything new to add to poetry,
poetry doesn't need
you, so we're good.
There are some people
who have to be in it,
and I welcome in
the space, but I
think what we're
trying to create
are poetically-minded
people, right?
And I will get into
this a little later when
I have my little
graph up, but the idea
that poetry storytelling,
art in general,
is a way to put down what's
going on in your life
into a space in front of you and
edit it and share it and make
it a useful tool as
opposed to the weight
that a lot of our trauma
and a lot of things
that happen in our life
present themselves as.
And it's not just
for people who are
good at it, which is the other
thing, we'll get to that later.
So my name is Joseph Green.
I am the director
of youth programs
at Split This Rock in DC.
I am also a professional
spoken word artist
and motivational speaker,
whatever that means.
I'm also a person who is
in long-term recovery.
And when I talk about
poetry saving lives,
this is the example that I give.
So I'm going to do
another poem for you
all after I take
a drink of water
because this is
a lot of talking.
And then I'm going to tell
you the story of the poem.
How are y'all doing?
Are we good?
So far, so good.
Cool, awesome.
I'm assuming that
everybody out there
is also nodding at their desk.
I appreciate whomever,
and it's funny
because I'm looking
off into the--
as if they're all there.
This poem is called "Talk Ugly."
"The last time I saw
you alive I wish I
would have talked ugly to you.
Said, put the straw down.
No, I don't want to
take another line.
I should be writing them.
My friend, you are a
composer of music and magic.
Instruct your limbs to
serve a purpose greater
than self-indulgence.
Do not be fooled into thinking
your pain has sharper teeth
than anyone else's.
I had a chance, but said
nothing because I was high.
This is how I got started.
A bottle of Jack and a mirror.
Memories and scissors,
dreams drenched in ether,
sliced by razors, potential
rolled like $20 bills,
numbing the feeling on
the tip of my tongue
that I or this tongue should
be serving a greater purpose.
In a last ditch attempt
at self-assessment
I decided to look at my life
through the eyes of loved ones,
for they see everything,
especially the ugly.
From years of drug
use, from lying with,
to lying to angels, friends
I had forsaken taking so much
more than I had given.
I streamlined self-centeredness
into a science,
but there was a
righteousness there.
A willingness to craft these
ills to alchemy and poetry
into to a seer
stone, but honestly
how could I speak ugly
to you when I was yet
to speak it to myself?
In these nightmares of
hindsight there is no poetry.
No alliterations
to soften the blow.
Some realities have no
simile, truth is like truth.
How could I form my lips to
call your suicide a tragedy when
I left you alone in
that room, kept company
by narcotics and a
thousand ghosts draped
in your disappointments?
I can imagine all the voices
you heard, all but mine.
Smear make up on to
disgust if you must.
Trust the truth
is seldom pretty,
but she is always beautiful.
It is in times like
these that I need
you to please talk ugly to me.
My pain needs it.
Too many times we caress sadness
when it needs to be shaken,
torn from its place
of comfort, forced
to grow wings to survive or die.
Just don't tell me I can grow
up and be whatever I want.
Tell me that whatever I
want better be something
I'm willing to achieve.
That dreams will dissipate
under the weight of addiction,
and that there is a distinct
difference between living
like a rock star and
actually being one.
Sometimes, no matter how
many poems you've written,
you are just a
coke-head and a poser.
Fear not, we are all
divinely flawed individuals,
perfectly ugly.
There's no point in
hiding behind pretty lies.
We are the sum of
the hideous scars
that hold together the
remainder of our pretty pieces.
The last time I saw you alive,
the last time I saw you alive,
the last time I saw
you alive I wish I
would have talked ugly to you.
It would have been the most
beautiful thing I never said."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So here's one of
a million examples
of how poetry has saved lives.
So I did a lot of drugs
when I lived in New York.
And I had a few friends and
we rolled in the same circle,
and we became thick as thieves
or thick as drug users.
I don't know what the
phrase is, but you
understand what I'm getting at.
I was fortunate enough to have
still a close relationship
with my family, which
is to say that I really
wasn't talking to them, but
they were still talking to me.
So I knew in the
back of my head,
behind all of the
damage and the drugs
and the fear and the
guilt and the shame
that my family was still there.
My friends didn't
have that same thing.
About three years
into it all, I hit
what we call in the biz
the proverbial rock bottom,
and I went back home to DC.
My father is a
recovering alcoholic
helped me into recovery.
And not just
physically here you go,
but like through his life
and his story, and the fact
that he had overcome
this demon in his life.
His life was a statement
of inspiration.
A year later I get a phone call.
My friend John has committed
suicide in a hotel room.
And I went back
up to the funeral.
And as is too often the
way in this space, when
we have lost one of our
own, those of us who
suffer from substance
use disorder,
we tend to mourn by
doing the same thing that
killed the person
that we loved, right?
So it's go to the funeral, go to
the bar, go to someone's house,
snort it away, shoot
it away, drink it away.
After the funeral
I had a choice.
Do I go to the bar?
Even though it's
been a year now.
Or do I go back
to my hotel room?
I had this line in my head, if
I had only talked ugly to you.
I've been a writer for a
while, so every once in a while
you get a line that sticks in
your head and it's just there
and it's gnawing at
you and it's annoying,
and you don't know
where it's going to go.
I decided to go back
to my hotel room--
sorry, dramatic pause over--
and I wrote the first
draft of this poem
that I just read for you,
which is when I first wrote it,
it was six pages long.
And I believe that--
you know, there's no
way to prove this--
there was a crossroads there.
I had been exposed to art, the
transformative power of art
enough that I was able
to make a decision that I
think saved my life.
I don't know if
I would have used
that night and OD'd or whatever,
because that's typically
what happens.
You go a long period of time,
you mess up, you go back,
and your body can't handle it.
But I didn't, so there you go.
It goes further
than that though.
I didn't just sit on it, right?
I took the poem to
a friend of mine.
He helped me edit it.
I presented it at a
poetry competition.
It did well.
But that's not
what was important,
what was important
is the young lady who
came up to me
afterwards and said,
I haven't known what to do about
this situation that I'm in.
I have a friend who's using
and she's going too far.
Thank you for telling
me your story,
because now I know what to do.
I want to be very
clear about this.
For everybody who
has lost somebody,
there is no guarantee
that saying something
will change what happened.
But the inverse of
that is also true.
There's no way of knowing
if you had said something
what change it could have made.
And so when given that
sort of logical argument,
you move forward.
You do the thing.
And that has repeated
itself 100,000 times since.
That one poem got heard
by this group of people,
who told that group of people.
And now I have the privilege
to go around the country
and share my story based on this
poem that I wrote a decade ago.
It saves my life
every time I do it.
It reminds me of
what's at stake.
And hopefully it has
been used as inspiration
to people who do this work
to keep at it because there's
very little reward in it.
And for those who are
actually suffering,
young people, to make a
change and make a choice
and make a decision to
do something about it.
But now that speaks to my work.
Now, how does that speak to
my work now as an educator?
I think any demographic
gets its own best
advocate for whatever it is
that's ailing that demographic.
For example, my poem is
powerful, I like to think.
It is twice as
powerful coming out
of the mouth of
someone who you believe
is going through a
similar time of life
or a similar understanding
of the world as you are.
So empowering young people--
if the last month
in America hasn't
proven to you what happens
when young people are fed up,
have had enough, and are
speaking to each other,
and are making things happen
regardless of whether or not
we give them permission to do
so, there's a lot of things
that we can talk about
as far as this movement
coming out of Florida.
I was honored enough to speak
at a local march a week before.
And I spoke about
the intersectionality
of race and gun violence and
how it's super important for us
to bring all that
stuff to the table.
And that argument and that
conversation needs to happen,
but the fact of the
matter is this population,
who we often write off as
being so self-absorbed to not
actually be able to do
anything other than worry about
themselves, have created this
space where now a generation
of young people--
it's a long game, right?
It's not like--
2018, are enough
of them going to be
able to vote that they change
the landscape of politics?
I don't know, but I
know now that there
are millions more
young people on notice
that are paying attention,
that will register to vote,
that understand
social activism to be
a part of the contract of
being a citizen of a country.
And that is powerful, and
they did it with words, right?
They did it by speaking
to one another.
They did it by
sharing their stories.
If you look at the
footage of the march,
most of those
presentations were stories
of what happened to them, not
statistics, even though they
were there.
It was story because that is
what gets the metric moving.
You can sit next
to someone and say,
this many people died
from gun violence.
And the reaction is--
because it's hard to put
humanity into numbers--
you can sit next to somebody and
say, this is how my son died,
or this is how I almost
died, or this is what's
happening in my neighborhood.
This is the fear that I feel,
and I look like your daughter,
and I look like your son.
How would you react?
And now that puts them on
blast, as we like to say.
I don't know who the we is.
I like to say,
put them on blast,
to where they have to
address the humanity
and choose to ignore it or not.
And that's something else, it
gets to people's real motives
and things.
Because how can you
sit next to someone
who is opening themselves up,
who is crying, who is broken,
and say, no, I still
think the thing
that broke you is more important
than how you feel right now.
This motivation is coming
from somewhere else.
I'm getting a little
bit off track,
but that was a really
important thing for me
to talk about because
it's happening right now.
I thought that it
would be appropriate
for me to bring an example
of how my young people--
my young people, I like to think
of them as my young people--
how the young people I work
with have taken their story
and created it into a tool for
advocacy, a tool for change.
And so I have a video
that I'm going to present.
If you're watching out
there you want to hang on.
This is going to
be amazing video.
Whatever you thought
of what I just did,
these young people do
it 10 times better.
And so we're going to get on
that technical side of things
and we're going to
make this happen.
Instead, I'm going to
end with one last poem
before we get into the
Q&A. And I wasn't expecting
to do this poem, except for, if
you were here at the beginning,
this was the poem I was
going to do at the start.
And it's a sweeter poem.
You might even laugh.
"In a dream I saw the
adolescent version
of myself leaning against the
wall at a middle school dance.
Appearing nervous
with our head down,
he seemed wanting, if not
needing of some advice.
I pulled out a napkin,
composed a letter.
A literal self-help manual.
Slipped it into my
own prepubescent hand,
looked down and read.
Dear me, dance.
Though you will not be good
at it until your early 20s.
Bear witness to how
solar systems are created
within the orbits of thighs, how
stars always seem to burn out,
but shine on as you two-step
through the universe,
don't forget to breathe.
If she approaches,
it was meant to be.
If not, Big Dipper
or supernova, you
will discover painfully that
the wonder behind dancing,
like love, is not solely
predicated on the idea
that you will always
have another there
to do it with you.
You will often find that you are
doing dancing and loving alone,
but don't you dare stop.
Dear me, or best friend an
imaginary turtle could have,
pick a job, a trade, a hobby,
anything, just not only art.
I'm hungry.
And while this poetry is
feeding my soul, the rest of me
is famished.
Dear me, or future
obsessive compulsive,
you have an addictive
personality.
Do not try drugs.
You are going to
like them a lot.
They will cause you to forget,
to lose things, most of which
the universe will never
see fit to give you
a second chance
with, all of which
will break your mother's heart.
Dear me, or would-be
knight in shining armor,
there are monsters
underneath your father's bed.
Those videotapes and
magazines are not manuals.
Only the wrong
kind of people will
want to be treated that way.
Yes, there is such a thing
as the wrong kind of person.
You will have a hand
in creating some.
Warning, the people labeled
broken-on-arrival cannot be
saved, just loved and accepted,
as you will one day hope to be.
Joseph, put down the blade.
Lower the heat in the shower.
Pens are not tourniquets,
paper a poor Band-aid.
It will be years before poetry
will attempt to yellow sun,
red cape, Superman
save you, stop it now.
Your soul will heal long
before those scars do.
Dear four-eyed
oracle, some wounds
won't heal magically
with mother's kiss.
Won't make sense
for years to come.
This is just a writing exercise.
There's no sense in it all.
If I could actually give
you life in a manuscript,
the instructions would simply
read, only change the parts
where you hurt people.
Everything else is miracle.
Besides, what's the
worst that could happen?
You grow up to be me, a
shattered but mending,
sometimes unemployed
literary freestyle
specialist with a vampire's
thirst for the universe's
lifeblood.
And young man, I have
loved you all along.
Sincerely, Joseph LMS Green."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I am also that guy with his face
plastered on his own website.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi.
My name's Aniyah.
I'm 17 years old, and my
poem is called "Dependence."
"The girl in my math
class thinks the best way
to go is by her own hand.
Says she wants to wear
a noose like a necklace
and know how it feels to have
sadness stands by her bedside.
I want to lend her mine.
To give her the bits
of this brokenness
and let her try it on like
a second-hand sweater,
feel the weight of every
suicide note on her chest,
and show her how it feels
to make breathing a chore,
and make her rethink making
this seem less burden and more
beauty, but who am I to judge
her when I'm still writing
my sickness in present tense?
As if depression and I still be
lovers entangled beneath my bed
sheets, instead of a
distant darling that
smells like yesterday's
dirty laundry,
the kind I never
bothered to do anyways
because for once
something smelled worse
than the stench of death
I grew far too fond of
because what else would
you expect someone who
was already dead to smell like?
And maybe I like being sick.
Maybe it makes me feel
interesting, or feel
anything at all
because the numbness is
enough to drive me crazier
than they already think I am.
I'd rather be
suffering than stoic.
And maybe that
makes me a masochist
for wanting to die just to feel
alive, just to feel at all.
And is it still relapse when
you never really recover?
When you threw away
the razors, but didn't
stop hurting yourself.
Just learned to make scars
that don't show up on skin.
Is it still relapse
when you're doing it
because you love yourself?
Because your body
believes it's bloodshed,
a sacred kind of beauty, thinks
you're more martyr than murder.
Is it still self-harm when
it doesn't hurt anymore?
When it's so easy to
want to stop breathing,
it's like breathing is still
self-harm when you like it.
When it feels good to
feel this bad, still bad.
When it's more security
blanket than sickness.
Feel safe in its grasp
because you know if you go,
it'll be by your own doing.
Without it, you are
a glass half empty,
and it's no fun having
a head above water
when you're used to
being so full of sadness
you're drowning.
And when the girl
in my math class
says she wants to know how
it feels to be suicidal,
I will want to lend
her my sadness,
but won't because after
all, what am I without it?"
- Hi, my name is Lauren.
And the name of my
poem is "So Far Gone."
"Three teenagers squish
into the back seat, cloudy.
The blunt is finally
passed and ash falls,
burns a hole in her sweatshirt.
She doesn't notice.
She wonders just
how far gone are you
when you know how to manipulate
the backseat of a car
better than your confidence?
Just how far gone
are you when you
can read minds and take orders
before they are even spoken?
Just how far gone
do you have to be
before you realize you're
going in the wrong direction?
See, nobody ever
asks after the kids
who familiarize themselves with
the contours of a back seat.
Or the kids who
can twist and bend
our bodies to angles too
acute and obtuse to ever
be considered right.
Nobody ever asked how
corrupted their minds have
to be to feel at home in the
confines of a clouded car.
Nobody ever ask about the
correlation between drug use
and sexual assault, smoke
and ashes, liquid's emission.
How far gone do they have to be?
How far gone was I that I
couldn't bear to lift a hand,
kick a leg in defiance?
How far gone are you when
your body feels like noodles
in the hands of a two-year-old?
Putty, clay, ready to
be molded and folded.
Real boy turned Pinocchio.
Lifeless limbs.
Soul-less stares.
Heavy hands.
Liquid lust.
Still smoke.
Nobody ever asked if
the kid's so depressed
that they get high just
to balance out their lows.
So backseats are all they know.
How far gone do they have
to be before somebody
realizes that they are
not doing this for fun?
Memorizing contours and
controls of backseats.
Taking orders before
they are spoken.
Too far gone to protest.
How far gone do we have to
be for somebody to send help?
How far gone will we be when
somebody finally sends help?"
- I think I wrote this
poem for two reasons.
One was to sort
through and kind of
figure out all the things
that I was feeling in regards
to my own mental health.
And the second
was because I feel
like it's so important for not
only youth, but youth of color,
to hear poems like this
about mental health,
to kind of release the
stigma around it because
in the African-American
community,
especially it's something
that's not talked about.
You keep it kind of hush, hush.
You keep it in the closet.
They tell you
like, go to church.
Pray about it.
Like I wanted to write this
poem to give not only myself
a voice, but other
people a voice
for what might be going
on inside of their head.
I think one big correlation
between addiction and substance
abuse and mental illness,
especially when it comes
to youth, is sometimes when
we say things about the way
that we're feeling, we're
not taken seriously.
So we want to take
it into our own hands
and to make this feeling
go away in any way
possible that we can.
So you start finding things,
anything, to take away
how you're feeling.
And I equate addiction
a lot of the time
with self-harm because people
look at it and they're like,
oh, they're doing that
to take away the pain.
But I think addiction
is the same thing.
Kids who are self-medicating,
using pot, or like prescription
drugs are doing the
exact same thing
that kids who are
self-harming are doing.
It's us trying to do
whatever we can to take away
those feelings that
we're feeling when
people aren't listening to us.
[END PLAYBACK]
JOSEPH GREEN: So yeah, those
are two of the young people
that I work with.
And I think those poems
speak for themselves.
And if you add
what I said earlier
about what the work
does when people see it,
you realize why it is
important for those poems
to be coming out of those
bodies to the young people who
are listening.
Telling a young person
that if they do drugs,
bad things will happen.
Well, it wasn't
effective for me.
And so I can't
imagine-- and I know
from work in these spaces-- that
it's not effective for them.
But to hear someone who
has gone through it,
who is two years older than
you, and is brave enough
to come out and say this in
front of a group of people,
the goal is hopefully
we can prevent people
from having to
live it to know it.
Hi.
SPEAKER: Hi, thank you.
Thanks for a very powerful
and authentic presentation.
I appreciate that.
I wanted to start with
a question that really
talks about intersectionality.
You gave us so much of your
personal self and very freely
were vulnerable and shared
your personal story.
And so it prompted
me to want to talk
to you about the
intersectionality
between our
self-talk, about what
happened between like last
year and this year, what
do people normally do.
And you wrestled
in your self-talk
with what choice were
you going to make.
Were you going to go to the bar?
Where you going to
go to your hotel?
But then you also
told your story.
And I think that both
of those are in play.
That there's an intersection
between the story
we tell ourselves and
actually telling our story.
JOSEPH GREEN: Yes.
OK, so to sum it up as quickly
as possible, to fit in more--
this is me telling myself so I
don't speak too much because I
tend to talk too much.
Once you have your story,
anything of real value
can only fulfill this
potential when it's shared.
You think of love.
You think of wisdom.
You think of joy.
All of those things are
great when you have it,
but they're best when they're
shared in communion, right?
And so the same thing
with, all right, I
have this voice in
my head telling me
to try to do the right thing.
How did that voice get there?
Well, it got there because
other people around me
at some point in time
had implanted it,
through lessons, through me
just seeing things happen
or whatever.
The purposefulness of the
conversation with my father.
The intentionality behind
the parts of his life
that he then opened
up and shared with me.
Those were all there
forming that voice.
And so that was wisdom
that other people had
that they shared, and it
came to fruition for me
in that moment when I was
able to make that decision.
And so when you work with young
people, or you have children,
you realize that
you aren't going
to be there to make the
decision for them, right?
So when they get
there, you want them
to have every tool possible.
And if knowing that you
had already been there
would be a deterrent from
them making the decision,
then you have an obligation
to share that you were there.
And that, again, not necessarily
in a spoken word poem, but just
a conversation, or in front
of your classroom or wherever
it is.
And I think our society is
made worse by the misconception
that professionalism means no
vulnerability and no openness
to one's true self.
People work in
cubicles for 20 years
beside someone who could
be from the same town
that they're from,
but they never
have a conversation about that
because that's not supposed
to happen in the workplace.
Well, I spend 60
hours at work a week.
If I'm not meeting
people, if I'm not
connecting with other
human beings in that space,
when am I doing it?
And the same thing
for young people.
Like my son is in
school 40 hours a week.
If they're not teaching
him how to connect
with other young people and
seek truth and connectivity
through sharing your
own story, then they're
just teaching them
how to take tests.
And that's I think a
disservice to our humanity.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Last week at Google we had
Dr. Bren Brown here who does
research in the field
of vulnerability--
JOSEPH GREEN: Yeah,
very familiar.
SPEAKER: And she described
vulnerability as uncertainty,
taking risk, and
emotional exposure.
And you represented
all of that--
JOSEPH GREEN: Well,
I wish one day
that her and I could
be in the same room,
and I can say thank you for
what her work has done for me.
It wasn't so much that
she presented it and I was
like, oh, vulnerability.
It was she allowed me
to put a name to it.
And the easier I can
access it and reference it,
the easier I can give
it to other people.
And so I really appreciate
her work and what she does.
It's cool that
anything I do like
brought her name
up in your head.
SPEAKER: Yeah, that's awesome.
Well, it also made me think, as
I was listening to that, about
vulnerability and
certainly, you gave us
a lot of exposure into your
emotions and into your life.
And a lot of people use the
spoken word as an outlet.
So it's something that they
do on the side as a way
to nurture and do self-care.
What do you do for self-care?
What's your outlet?
JOSEPH GREEN: So meditation.
Meditation, meditation.
It seems so simple, but
practice, having a practice
of anything, whether
it's yoga, or kickboxing,
or whatever, meditation,
having a consistent thing
over and over again, it
brings you back down to earth
when the world is
trying to tether
that string with
all of the stress
and BS that is everyday life.
I try not to flirt with
the idea of-- you know,
with greater meaning,
why are we here?
So on and so forth.
But it allows me to
look at the battles that
are right in front of me and
say, OK, come back to yourself.
Humble yourself.
Relax yourself so that you can
be the best version of yourself
to continue to do this work.
Because it's bruising, right?
Whenever you help someone
else with their trauma,
you expose yourself
to that trauma,
and therefore, it becomes a
traumatic experience for you
also.
And I think people who
do this work sometimes
find that out, most times
find that out the hard way.
They was like, they wanted
to do it their whole life.
They've been in social work
for three years and all
of a sudden they're
burned out, and they can't
do anything about it anymore.
And they can't feel anymore.
I think I hit that road
maybe five years ago.
And then mindfulness,
Buddhism, all of those things
came into my life.
And that's how I
take care of myself.
And to try to spend as
much time with the people I
love as I possibly can.
SPEAKER: So recently
there have been incidents
in places from
Sacramento to Parkland
that have impacted
families and young people
to create movements, like March
Our Lives, that you referenced.
How are the kids you work with
using these to create movements
to change our world?
And how can adults engage
and support our children?
JOSEPH GREEN: OK.
So what we do in DC
with Split This Rock
and the spoken word movement
that we have in DC is not new.
We're not the only organization
in America doing it.
And I can think of 15
in California alone.
Resources speak volumes.
So I have young people
who do poetry slams.
And they look out
in the audience
and they see five adults.
Before I came here, the
day before I came here,
was our grand slam final.
The five young
people, they've been
part of hundreds
of young people who
have been trying to get
to this one little space.
And the adults in the room gave
validation to their experience.
They also paid to get
in, so that helps also
to allow them to go on this
trip now to the Brave New Voices
competition, that's sponsored
by Youth Speaks, which is out
of the Bay Area.
And it's that.
When we talk about what are the
revolutionary things that we
can do on a daily
basis, it's not always
destroying or tearing
something down,
even though that is
necessary and a natural part
of existence.
But the conversations that
they have, the creativity that
is shared, and doing
everything they
can to create these
spaces and then back up.
I create space.
I bring in facilitators who talk
about social justice issues,
and then I go away.
And I let what's going to
happen in that space happen.
And then when the young
people come to you
and say, I have this idea,
well, how can you hope make
that idea come to fruition?
And I think the
March for Our Lives
is a great example of that.
Young people had an idea.
They didn't have
the money to do it.
They had the idea.
Adults gave them the
support that they could,
the years of wisdom and
experience and resources,
and they were able to
make this idea happen,
and they get out of the way.
And look what's going on.
Yes.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious to know.
Something I really
connect with you
is sharing like an
authentic voice in story.
I'm wondering if
you ever kind of had
wanted to release
a poem, or didn't,
because it kind of affected
someone else in your life?
Because I feel a lot of that
messaging is share your story.
And I've wanted to
share certain things
and then people
are like, well, you
know, if you're in
a bad relationship
or someone in your
family has hurt you,
how do you know to like cross
that line of sharing versus you
might really hurt
someone in your life?
JOSEPH GREEN: That is a very
great question and something
that I have dealt with directly.
So I alluded to
my father earlier.
I have a poem that's just
about our relationship,
and how I ran into
addiction, running away
from the broken man that
I had saw growing up,
and how him seeking
recovery when I needed it,
he was there for me.
So it ends well.
But to do that I had to expose
certain things about him
that members of our
family didn't know.
And I think that
there's two things.
One, you always have
to measure for yourself
is the juice worth the squeeze.
The juice for me in
this space was the lives
that I think I have affected
and maybe even partially saved--
been part of the saving of--
because I was willing to
put that story out there.
I remember that night he
saw it the first time.
I did it for him an event.
My parents don't come out
to a lot of my events.
The spoken word world isn't
really where they hang out.
They're church folks.
But they do support
when they can.
So he came out, I said, dad,
I've been doing this poem.
I feel kind of bad that I
haven't done it in front
of you, or shared it with you.
So I gave him a
book with it in it,
and then I did the poem in front
of this place of 200 people.
And in that moment he
cried and gave me a hug
and it was beautiful.
Fast forward six months.
I'm at a different event,
somebody records it.
They ask if they
can put it online.
It's going to go to some
people who do this work,
and they can use the poem,
maybe 600 people or so.
It gets picked up by not
BuzzFeed, somebody else,
one of those things.
And it goes viral.
And all of a sudden
he's getting phone calls
from family members, did you
know your son put this out
about you?
And then it became a problem.
And then he read the
comments underneath the poem.
And I think that's
where his anger went.
I think that if you've
messed up in your life
at some point in
time, and you know
that there are going to be
people who are made better
or made whole by
hearing your story,
if your heart is
in the right place,
you learn how to suck it up.
You know, you realize
that this is a good thing.
That being said, I've
seen it go both ways.
It's your story though.
And we can't interact with
people in this world assuming
that if I do something
bad, they're never
going to say anything about it.
Because that's
two wrongs, right?
That's the wrong of
me doing the thing,
and then the wrong of me
hoping that you don't share it,
which means that you
have to sit on this thing
that I did to you.
And that's not fair.
So as long as it's your
story and you're not
using it to purposely
defame someone,
I think you have
to do it, personal.
Juice is worth the
squeeze though.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOSEPH GREEN: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you
for coming to Google.
We so appreciate
your being here.
I know it was about 18
months to get you here.
How do we stay in contact and
continue the conversation?
JOSEPH GREEN: Yes.
So I would love for everyone
who's out there listening right
now to just find me online.
You can go to my website
and it's lmsvoice.com,
as in last man
standing, lmsvoice.com,
or it's Joseph LMS Green
on all social media.
I do my best to post
stories of the young people
that I work with.
I do my best to
tell the experiences
that I'm going through.
I use my social media
to hopefully bring joy,
because I feel like that's the
most important thing that I
can give.
I've fought so hard to
get it and to share it.
So that's what you would be
getting if that's the case.
And also, if you're
a person out there
who works with
people who you think
could benefit from
the work that we do,
if you shoot me an email
through my website,
we have an online curriculum
at Split This Rock
that is free for everybody.
And I will send you
the link to that.
And it's hundreds of
workshops and writing prompts
and ways to start
clubs and movements
in your own community.
So either one of those things.
Please be in touch.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
JOSEPH GREEN: Happy to be here.
Thank you.
And thank all of you!
[APPLAUSE]